[Música]
les doy la bienvenida un nuevo episodio
de boleto de vuelta que en esta ocasión
no lleva a rumanía país que durante la
segunda guerra mundial fue escenario de
múltiples masacres 6 millones de judíos
fueron exterminados en el holocausto y
fue en europa del este donde este
balance fue más fuerte
polonia ucrania hungría y rumanía se
considera que hasta 380 mil judíos
fueron asesinados ahí la mayoría por la
policía bajo las órdenes del dictador
ion antonescu aunque también con la
participación de la población local en
el verano de 1941 rumanía aliada de la
alemania nazi envió su ejército a
moldavia ocupada por tropas soviéticas
la represalia la ciudad de iasi cerca a
la frontera fue bombardeada los
movimientos fascistas y antisemitas eran
poderosos la población judía de la
ciudad se volvió de inmediato un
objetivo la policía y el ejército
lanzaron el ataque junto con habitantes
numerosos judíos fueron asesinados otros
fueron amontonados en trenes de la
muerte en condiciones espantosas muchos
murieron de hambre se asfixia una décima
parte de la población de jacques fue
masacrada en pocos días se estima que
hubo más de 13.000
actualmente estos hechos son ampliamente
ignorados por la población rumana pero
algunos luchan contra el olvido y el
negacionismo
[Música]
y al noreste de rumanía la segunda
ciudad más poblada del país acoge
también un cementerio casi abandonado
[Música]
más de 100 mil sepulturas llevan
apellidos de familias judías una
comunidad reducida actualmente a 3000
personas en el país
olga aquí mira administra el cementerio
judío de la ciudad desde hace 25 años
esta mujer sin edad vive en medio de los
muertos
diariamente recorre con perros
callejeros los caminos de una necrópolis
que conoce de memoria
y
me aprendí los senderos principales y
también las divisiones del cementerio
la división 1 la división 2 el grupo b
el grupo se ve grupo h
este es el pogromo la fosa común en la
fosa común están todos enterrados
normales gripe común
el pogromo de jazz una de las peores
masacres de la segunda guerra mundial
iniciada por el dictador rumano ion
antonescu
más de 13.000 personas fueron asesinadas
entre el 28 de junio y el 6 de julio de
1941 porque eran judías
los descendientes de quienes fueron
asesinados tienen
por estos muertos espero vivir lo que
más pueda
vivir por los muertos y conservar su
historia sacada del olvido porque
durante mucho tiempo el recuerdo del
pogromo estuvo enterrado
porque la memoria de esos días de horror
estuvo confiscado durante tanto tiempo
porque sigue siendo tan desconocida que
queda de esta tragedia preludio del
exterminio de 6 millones de judíos de
europa durante la segunda guerra mundial
archivos y fotografías insoportables
tomadas en esencia por soldados alemanes
tales como estas en el museo del pogromo
de ellas
[Música]
pero también escasos testimonios en
bucarest a leonard chess 95 años es uno
de los últimos sobrevivientes del
pogromo
el día anterior al pogromo del 28 de
junio de 1941 recuerdo haber leído en un
volante un buen judío es un judío muerto
un bond
a sus 14 años leonard site school o
vivió todo el horror de los asesinatos a
bala en la prefectura de policía
e indiferencia y las violencias
populares pero también la pesadilla de
los trenes de la muerte con el objetivo
de matar
salió vivo pero su padre no
el tren o
el tren que salió de jazz con destino a
proa y si recuerdo bien
1997 judíos fueron embarcados en vagones
normalmente hecho para animales en
general este tipo de vagones se puede
meter 8 caballos de pie y tal vez 40
personas pero nosotros éramos más de 130
por vagón
y estábamos amontonados ahí adentro es
por ello que tantos perecieron
y no hablo de nuestros sufrimientos
debido a la falta de agua la gente
chupaba sus labios llenos de sangre y
finalmente a veces no encontraban otra
solución distinta a orinar en sus
camisas
exprimían sus camisas llenas de orina en
su boca se limpiaban el rostro con ellos
mucha gente no contaba con ropa estaba
desnuda
en el interior había escenas
inimaginables
una violencia inaudita la población
denuncio saqueo golpeó participó en los
asesinatos de sus vecinos judíos pero
las masacres fueron orquestadas en
especial por las autoridades rumanas y
sus brazos armados la policía y los
militares secundados por soldados
alemanes
muy pocos procesos crímenes impunes
yo no sé genocidio alecsandro florian es
el director del instituto eligiese el en
bucarest
un instituto público de investigación
sobre el holocausto world donde son
conservados archivos oficiales también
es el hijo de un sobreviviente de los
trenes de la muerte
son documentos muy importantes que
prueban la responsabilidad de las
autoridades romanas de las instituciones
del estado podemos decir el ejército
romano y el ministerio del interior el
gobierno romano
este documento está firmado por jon
antonescu verdad
hacer reconocer la culpabilidad del
régimen fascista de antonescu en el
holocausto sin entregarle la culpa
únicamente a la alemania nazi fue una
lucha de largo aliento
tan solo en 2004 rumanía reconoció
oficialmente su culpabilidad
pero el camino aún es largo
más o menos el 25% de la población entre
el 25 y 30 por ciento conoce actualmente
de manera correcta la historia de las
hojas de romana stuart de las hermanas
de hecho la historia del holocausto es
una materia opcional en la escuela una
ley sobre la educación acaba de ser
adoptada un avance significativo en el
2023 la enseñanza de la shoá será
obligatoria en los vídeos rumanos
[Música]
pero el desconocimiento del holocausto
también fue agravado durante 40 años por
un régimen comunista que trató de
rehabilitar las instituciones reduciendo
a los judíos rumanos y sus historias al
silencio
tal como duch su leibovich quien perdió
a su padre en el pogromo de judge
esa noche en el centro comunitario judío
de piatra neamt una ciudad en el noreste
del país menciona un temor que lo
atormenta el regreso de las horas
oscuras de la historia
sabes y hubo señales previas del pogromo
si las hubo
hoy usted se personaban de cero
nunca quise venganza personal por mi
padre la gente fue manipulada
formación
tal como hoy en día con esta formación
política legalmente constituida un
partido que no quiero nombrar
es el partido a ur de la alianza por la
unidad de los rumanos
un partido xenófobo que para mí tiene un
discurso que hace pensar en la época
nazi
santuario
tema existe
[Música]
para sorpresa general el partido a la
alianza por la unidad de los rumanos
ingresó al parlamento a finales de 2020
con el 9 por ciento de los sufragios el
hombre fuerte de la formación política
es el george unión uno de los
presidentes del partido un importante
núcleo está gracias la nivel de esport
universitat filial
somos un partido antisistema pero no
somos un partido anarquista somos un
partido que quiere cambiar el sistema en
funcionamiento desde la caída de
ceaucescu
aun en busca de responsabilidad provoca
sin embargo con frecuencia escándalos
declaraciones revisionistas elogios a
criminales de guerra en pleno senado
intento de asalto al parlamento por los
simpatizantes acompañado permanentemente
por su camarógrafo georges simion
trabaja su comunicación alimentando sus
redes sociales
vintage
haga clic sobre el botón suscríbete se
conectan con un correo electrónico y
serán los primeros en recibir
notificaciones cuando tengamos nuevos
contenidos en el blog y youtube
este antiguo ultra niega que su partido
sea de extrema derecha y asegura amar al
pueblo judío
sin embargo esto es lo que se puede leer
en la página de agua del que es
presidente
aún reprochó a los nuevos programas
querer poner en primera fila temas que
son temas menores de la historia tales
como educación sexual o historia del
holocausto
el holocausto reducido por ahora un tema
menor de la historia y sin embargo
detrás de la alemania nazi rumanía es el
país que exterminó a la mayor cantidad
de judíos durante la segunda guerra
mundial actualmente el partido
nacionalista progresa de manera
espectacular en los sondeos
un clima político que preocupa al
director del instituto el y diesel
alexandru florian perdió a su abuelo en
uno de los trenes de la muerte y ya se
encuentra en el memorial de la shoah
prendemos gran pero vemos el nombre de
mi abuelo el día se llamaba esta es la
historia
alecsandro florian busca en el espacio
público las manifestaciones insidiosas
del negacionismo
tal como en este barrio residencial de
la capital donde trata de hacer tumbar
esta estatua de la gloria a merche a
volcanes con un intelectual rumano
condenado por crímenes de guerra
y la eterna hombre de mármol
antonescu de prisión y de carácter fue
miembro del gobierno ion antonescu entre
enero de 1941 y el final el 23 de agosto
de 1944 pero hace diez años a la
alcaldía de esta localidad le dedicó
este gusto pero el texto el mensaje no
dice nada sobre su pasado de criminal de
guerra
son pases de criminal de guerra
para enfrentar esta negación de la
historia una nueva generación de
investigadores comprometidos ha surgido
en rumanía se construyen los discursos
nacionalistas
el gobierno nombró el año pasado un
representante especial para la memoria y
la lucha contra el antisemitismo
a su manera el teatro judío del estado
de bucarest lucha contra el olvido y el
negacionismo
maya morgenstern actriz renombrada
internacionalmente es la directora del
lugar
vamos a presentar ante el público la
bitácora de la rebelión y de los
crímenes legionarios
es un testimonio un grito de
desesperanza una elección
podemos llegar al corazón el cerebro la
inteligencia hacer preguntas reservo
lawn tenis jones un tipo de cuestión
esta noche los comediantes se preparan
para conmemorar a las víctimas de otro
pogromo el de bucarest
entre el 21 y el 23 de febrero de 1941
los legionarios de la guardia de hierro
saquean el barrio judío de la capital y
asesinan a sus habitantes
vas a llevar una equipa tú también no yo
no soy el enemigo
esta noche voy a representar a un joven
legionario que asiste a la muerte de un
hombre frente a él y en ese lapso sigue
comiendo y dice no es grave es un judío
no tengo palabras es horrible
es horrible
y
entre 280.000 y 380 mil judíos rumanos y
ucranianos murieron bajo la
administración de john antonescu
[Música]
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta al pogromo de jazz y
recuerda que si quiere ver este y otros
episodios en español puede visitar
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hasta pronto